ce fossé effectivement il est entre le
pedigree entre guillemets précédent du
terroriste et puis les actes qu'il a
commis
comment l'opinion peut le percevoir
alors on a finalement la question c'est
que c'est un type lambda dans la masse
des des clandestins qui commet des actes
effroyables
en fait on est sûr janvier sur un sujet
un petit peu explosif ici et c'est
d'autant plus compliqué à expliquer à
l'opinion qu'on est à la croisée de deux
problématiques qui sont ultra sensible
pour les français et qui font partie des
préoccupations majeures
la question de l'immigration et la
question de la lutte contre le
terrorisme qui sont deux sujets dont on
l'a vu pendant toute la campagne
présidentielle qui ont vraiment été mise
au coeur des préoccupations des français
après la question notamment de l'emploi
et celle de l'europe donc on a ici deux
sujets très sensibles pour les français
qui sont qui se retrouvent corrélés et
qui rendent les français je pense assez
peu indulgent sur cette question de
temps moins indulgent que faut être il
faut être clair sur les questions
d'immigration les français sont quand
même une position assez assez dur et
quand on parle de l'immigration
clandestine
ils sont rarement du côté des
clandestins dans ce contexte là je pense
que la réaction elle est plutôt celle de
on n'a pas fait d'enquêté suite à
marseille mais d'un manque d'indulgence
et de compréhension sur le sujet
effectivement la question du jour du
figaro qui est l'attentât de marseille
as tu eu défaillance de l'état pour le
moment les réponses sur douze mille
votants sont fait 90 % de oui